they're the gangs that need no cover
with weapons worse than you'd find on
the streets
these are Tanzania's blast fishermen
using homemade bombs to bag bigger
caches but we can reveal what they're
trying to hide
Coral once teeming with life turned into
ocean wastelands we've spent a year
investigating this trade and have seen
data suggesting they blasted 55,000
times we've been out for several hours
and we've seen six blasts fishermen and
several blasts and the fishermen we're
with here don't want to be identified
because of how dangerous these guys are
when you approach them sometimes they
will hold up their dynamite and threaten
to throw it at you and it doesn't stop
there
Hyacinthe was a fisheries officer who
arrested 72 of them before they poured
acid over his face
the more than a ping is this is the
first time he has spoken out on camera
and he says the blasters hardly ever
went to jail only five person under
lenient sentence
most of the future is now they say if
you attacked like over here oh it's not
a good job that's why you can see the
dynamite has nowadays they're doing well
so well that they're now blasting in
sight of the country's gas wells the
owners and villagers patrol this ocean
but one blaster got within 100 meters
the damage would be catastrophic we
might lose either the pipeline the
processing plant can stop and the effect
can cascade to the national economic
impact and it is not only life and limb
under threat but whole ecosystems - from
fishing towns to desert islands it is
the same story
yes wonders disappearing bomb by bomb
piece like that takes over 50 years to
regrow again there's no life for many
creatures they're special fish they have
no homes
this actually disaster the men
responsible are often unrepentant and
are willing to take great risks to
plunder the Seas resources I saw friends
lose their limbs one even blew himself
up but it was a way of life we didn't
realize the damage we were doing to the
sea we took our story to the government
and they say they will break up the
gangs they're considering fish market
inspections and tough new laws I
personally feel that you know these
people should be charged on economic
sabotage act if nothing is done now at
this point in the next 10 years we won't
have life you know shores but right now
the blasting goes on even outside the
fishery officers house it's their final
insult to the man they have scarred and
with every bomb they scar the world
beneath the waves as well